okay in our first story apple maps for
ios 15
has been upgraded and i think it's a
pretty clear tell a tip off a clue as to
what apple is working on very diligently
i believe who knows if it actually
results in a product and when but if
you've upgraded to ios 15 which is a
major major major ios update and there's
a lot of buzz about it a lot of
interesting features facebook i'm sorry
facetime being one of them um and we've
been talking about some of the other
features like their safari email relay i
talked about yesterday where you can
basically tunnel and people don't know
what you're searching for well let's
take a look at this apple maps for a
second if you're watching on youtube or
the video podcast stream you can see
some great screen grabs and they're
really highlighting uh landmarks like
madison square garden okay that's nice
they did a little extra rendering on it
but you immediately start to notice that
this feels like you're playing in a
video game doesn't it it looks like the
matrix it looks like this is an actual
3d world well of course it is you are
clicking on the 3d button you see this
3d rendering and now here's coit tower a
very interesting look
they lit it up
and the golden gate bridge a nice
burgundy
or whatever orange that is i you know i
always hear people say red and then i
hear some people say it's burnt orange
uh the golden gate bridge but i think
all bridges should be painted a bold
color like the verrazano bridge between
staten island and bay ridge brooklyn
where i grew up imagine if that was
painted a bold color it was blue or
something uh here's lombard street the
famous uh sneaking street in san
francisco that a bunch of people go and
drive down and they wait an hour to
drive down the street the salesforce
tower looking great
so
if uh you're listening live
why is this look so good why do these 3d
renderings uh why are they investing in
3d
so much
when in fact 2d is better when you're
driving isn't it like this is nice to
look at but it's kind of unnecessary and
in fact
it's not as good of an experience as
using a 2d
uh overhead model when you're driving
you need directions like this is
obviously for a reason so if you're in
the chat room or you're
on twitter go ahead and give me your
theory
of why apple has enhanced
apple maps in ios 15 to this crazy level
with these 3d models uh augmented
reality uh lin lita says yeah maybe but
there's something more important in
there patrick got it the apple car very
clear uh that apple is taking their maps
product super seriously because once you
have maps and you have everybody with
these phones you know when a phone is
moving
over 35 miles an hour it's either
somebody in a car
uh or they are on a really fast bicycle
so
apple knows from your phone uh when you
are
driving in a car now how many iphones
are there what's the fidelity of gps
okay they've got a maps program you
click
when you use apple maps would you like
to give us feedback to help us refine
maps i'm guessing that that's somewhere
in the terms of service and they could
be
without us all explicitly knowing it but
i think you would
maybe assume that this is happening
refining the maps based on your gps data
somebody can look that up if they want
the terms of service does apple refine
the maps product when you're using it
based on your gps data i'm assuming they
do
now what that means is
they've got
instead of having cars on the road they
have phones on the road those phones are
iterating on the maps program just like
tesla's are live on the road and are
getting data or uber and lyft and fedex
trucks amazon delivery drivers excuse me
they are all
providing data to refine maps and uh it
may not be cameras like on a tesla where
they have video of every junction and
every weird moment when people slam on
their brakes or turn too hard all that
data is being put into these models to
build these 3d worlds these 3d worlds
are what self-driving is made of that's
why apple
is basically taking a page out of
google's playbook and tesla's
let's use google uses google maps data
obviously to inform waymo and waze data
you can be sure it's informing waymo in
some way and obviously tesla has been
very clear
that their million plus cars are on the
road some number of them have
self-driving whether it's been paid for
or turned on or not and that makes it
amazing for them to refine it in fact
back in 2017 tim cook confirmed apple
was working on autonomous software and
systems we know that we're focused on
autonomous systems it's a core
technology it's a quote that we view as
very important we sort of see it as the
mother of all ai projects it's probably
one of the most difficult ao projects
actually to work on now apple is super
secretive when they do
mention
a project and they expand and give
reasons or they give this sort of color
or texture as he does here about uh
autonomous systems that means they've
got it going on when they say hey we're
going to pull the string on augmented or
pull the string on you know tv and see
where it leads us yeah that means they
were going to launch apple tv both
content and the product so
we know that this is going to be a big
deal and in december of 2020 bloomberg
reported that apple shifted the
leadership team in their self
driving car unit which is called titan
giving the reigns over to top ai
executive john
uh gian andrea
i hope i pronounced that correct john
i'd love to have you in the program but
apple people are not allowed to go on
podcasts and talk about what you're
working on because i would ask you hey
what's next and you'd say uh we can't
talk about what's next so um people gave
apple a really hard time about software
and
how poorly they made their apps and
their software and actually i think they
and previously how poorly they did cloud
um
and any kind of uh cloud-based service
like remember mobileme how terrible that
was compared to icloud icloud's actually
pretty great now and so is uh their
services business
uh whether it's apple music delightful
product with a lot of nuance in it so i
think that's what we're seeing here is
apple is really getting much better at
cloud and much much better at building
software apple maps was a disaster it
was when it was released you can type in
apple maps launch and you can find all
the things that were wrong in it and now
you're starting to see they're taking it
seriously does this mean they're gonna
actually compete
in cars um yeah i'm not so sure i'm not
so sure that that's a market where
they're gonna
actually have great success it's a lot
harder than people think but i think
people said that with mobile phones too
when apple just made pc so i would never
uh underestimate apple they
seem to work on things for you know a
decade and
when they do release them they tend to
be pretty darn good
sometimes they take some five or six
versions i will say the apple watch was
one of those products i don't know if
you have an apple watch but it took
about six years to get good okay let's
go on to our next story
zendesk is the go-to tool for customer
support we all know that they also offer
a suite of tools designed to remove the
difficulties of sales software so get
zendesk suite of sales tools plus their
industry leading support software for
free for six months as part of zendesk
for startups i'll show you how to do
that in just a moment but i want you to
know that you'll also get access to
zendesk's community of startup founders
and partners and will even offer
dedicated onboarding guidance and
support you know steezy studios it's one
of our portfolio companies and they sell
software to learn how to dance hundreds
of thousands of people are using that
software and they want to make sure
everybody has a great experience with
the software obviously so through a
combination of zendesk explorer and
their ticket tagging system steezy is
able to track which features their users
are most excited about and then relay
that to the product team so they're
using customer support
to make the product better so for steezy
zendesk creates a positive relationship
with their members and empowers them to
contribute this these growth in return
for some awesome dance moves get six
months of zendesk for startups free at
zendesk.com twist to qualify you must
have under 50 employees that's
reasonable and you must have raised a
series a or below and be a new zendesk
customer couple conditions there because
they're giving you something really
valuable for free six months of zendesk
for startups start building the best
customer experiences at
zendesk.com twist